- I think this is hilarious.
Did you know that someone honored you
with a sandwich?
Did you know that there's
a sandwich named after you?
And it's awesome. (giggling)
- What?
- Yes, and I'm so jealous.
I want a sandwich (laughing)
So Sammich restaurant in Ashland Oregon
is serving the Queen Labeefa. (laughing)
(clapping)
The Queen Labeefa.
Come on.
- My assistant, Jonathan is handing me
- A queen Labeefa, yes.
Okay y'all,
I love you so much Jesse.
It comes with steak,
jalapeno cream cheese spread
and red onion on sourdough rice.
So I'm just saying we should taste it.
It's a Queen Labeefa,
cause that's just never
gonna not be funny.
This is the largest sandwich
in the entire world.
Oh, damn that's good.
Yeah.
- Is it good?
- Yes.
It's so good.
You're Queen Labeefa sandwich
is so good. (giggling)
- Look I'm about to spray
my Queen Labeefa sandwich. (laughing)
- (clapping) COVID friendly.
It is so good, you gotta try it.
It's so good.
Thank you so much Sammich
restaurant Ashland Oregon,
that was amazing.
Alright, so be sure y'all,
see like it, don't you?
It's so good.
Get that little bit, yeah. (laughing)
(crowd laughing)
You're so classy, I totally
talked with my mouth open.
I got to take lessons
on class from the queen.
- It's all about this right here.
- That's me too!
Yes,
It's so good
yeah, I meant to eat it too.
- Has that little kick
I know, I like some
spice, I like some spice.